el siguiente paralelogramo tiene un área
de 24 unidades cuadradas encuentra a la
altura aquí tenemos el paralelogramo
este lado tiene una longitud de 6 este
lado tiene una longitud de 5 y queremos
encontrar la altura y nos dan el área
pause del vídeo y traten de resolverlo
la clave para resolver esto es darse
cuenta cómo se relacionan la base y la
altura el área del paralelogramo es
igual a la base por la altura
ahora cuál es la base en este caso
podemos ver esta longitud que tenemos
aquí como la base que es la misma
longitud que este lado en un
paralelogramo los lados opuestos tienen
la misma longitud los lados paralelos
tienen la misma longitud así que este es
igual a 6 la base es igual a 6 y la
altura es lo que tenemos que encontrar
así que voy a escribir esto como la h
que tenemos que encontrar y conocemos el
área que es igual a 24 unidades
cuadradas entonces 24 es igual a 6 por
la altura cuál es el número que tenemos
que multiplicar por 6 para obtener 24 6
por 4 es igual a 24
así que h es igual a 4 unidades h es
igual a 4 unidades